look if there were any more trailers
that came out at Comic Con I'm just not
gonna talk about it last one I'm gonna
talk about huh Shazam
so Shazam premiered and like Godzilla
king of the monsters this is one I
forgot about which is why you're getting
more than one video a day which I really
don't like to do but I can't move other
stuff around I've got too much planned
so Shazam as a property has always been
kind of interesting to me as because of
its fundamental hook being that it is
about a young boy who becomes a
superhero it is such a youth fantasy in
your power fantasy fulfillment wish
fulfillment sort of thing it's one of
the few DC properties that hasn't gone
as hard into dark and gritty as almost
everything else because the there really
isn't much leeway to go super dark in a
premise as inherently light as this
that's not to say Shazam has never gone
dark but it's it's certainly been more
resistant to that sort of take than a
lot of DC properties have been
especially in the more recent decades
so with that taking into account it was
nice to see them again not trying to
Gritty up this premise actually there's
a number of things about the original
origin of that I was surprised and
gotten pleasantly surprised that they
kept such as the fact that that he gets
his powers by running into a wizard in a
subway station and that they managed to
kind of update that from the specifics
of the original origin in a way that
makes it a little less inherently creepy
than it actually was but it's I mean
that was cool I liked that I like the
vibe of the of the boy who's playing
young Billy and I really like his his
foster brother I like him a lot I like
their dynamic they
off each other really really really well
now when it comes to the adult version
the quote-unquote adult the physically
fit superhero version of Shazam it's not
bad it works that visually
appearance-wise like looking at the face
they you could buy that they're the same
person so that helps I did find myself
thinking that I wonder if the younger
actor and Shawn Levy Levi's I don't know
if I just completely know Zachary Levi
Shawn Shawn Shawn Levy is a direct oh
sorry Zachary Levi I don't know if this
is the case and when I see the whole
film it may turn out not to be the case
but in the trailer it felt to me like
both of them was slightly over
compensating for the adjustments that
they had to make so that they could
feasibly try and be the same person what
I mean by that is younger Billy seemed a
little more mature in his behavior than
Shazam did so it felt almost a little
bit like the younger actor was trying to
act slightly older so would it be more
believable when the older version
happens whereas the older version seemed
to be acting a little bit more childish
than the child actually was acting when
he was in the body of a child now there
are certainly ways that you can explain
that that you know circumstances that
forced him to become sort of mature
ahead of his time and that getting these
powers is a way to let his inner child
out a bit more so I mean you know there
are ways to make this work but I had
that thought while watching the trailer
I can't help but share it a bit the
overall vibe is light and I do
appreciate that could have done without
the P joke because that huh I never saw
this movie but I remember trade this was
like back in the 90s when trailers on
the front end of movies that you would
rent would be heavily loaded with
direct-to-video stuff I remember seeing
a trail of something called star kid
where like this kid finds an alien
like power suit and he said he's like I
need to pee and the suits like preparing
for urination and like this little thing
pops out of the chest like it's
expecting that to be where the kid pees
from and I remember thinking even at the
time and my young teams thinking that's
kind of dumb and this gave me that vibe
that joke
specifically did so and and that's
another way that that's a very
superficial way to ramp up the the
feeling of of immaturity of the
character and I have an inherent dislike
for that in the same way that I have an
inherent dislike of ramping up the quote
unquote maturity by having people swear
a lot you know it's it's this
superficial very surface level attempt
at immaturity that is kind of the flip
of the superficial attempts at maturity
that I already dislike and it kind of
rubs me the wrong way for the same
fundamental reason not as harshly as
forced maturity does but it is in the in
the same vein but the he still has good
chemistry and a good vibe with the
foster-brother
character which again I already liked so
I think I feel like that that
relationship is gonna be the major
through-line on this film it's gonna be
the major thing that carries it through
that and just sort of embracing the fun
because I think a big thing that a lot
of superhero movies have lost is that
it's being a super having superpowers is
a childhood fantasy and the reason it's
a childhood fantasy is because we think
it would be fun and that's not to say
that there's no validity and you know
having a superhero not be fun and have
them even not enjoy what they do and
like this is serious stuff someone like
Batman daredevil they're perfect for
that but I feel like it's an attitude
that is spread across a heck of a lot of
characters and it's nice to have
somebody who their powers are not a
burden
they are just awesome because like
honestly the closest we came to that is
like maybe spider-man homecoming but
even though it's been downplayed versus
say the the earlier iterations of
spider-man in film the whole great
response of great power great
responsibility thing Peter is still a
character driven by a certain amount of
guilt and you know even this even the
young version that we're now getting
that is still there a bit he feels a ton
of responsibility a ton of guilt
probably backing that up in terms of you
know wanting to use his power to help
people whereas the whole thing with
Shazam is he's a fundamentally good kid
that's why he gets picked and so when
he's given powers yeah he's gonna try
and help people even it's not even that
silly away is trying to charge people's
phones as he walks through the mall and
I I like that embracing of the fantasy
of superpowers as opposed to this
separates you from other people and they
will hate you or these are a burden or
you must be a broken person to wield
this pot no it's awesome dude can fly
and shoot lightning and he's bulletproof
that's awesome and I like that this
trailer embraces the element of that
being awesome I did select my my little
niggles my little knit picks on it but
it's nothing major and given that this
was one of the properties that I was the
most skeptical about I I'm not I'm not
going like I was would say the Titans
trailer dear God which in many ways this
almost feels like the antidote to that
trailer so yeah look solid I'll be
curious to see more about it in terms of
I believe we've got dr. sivana as the
villain who him stopping Shazam's punch
was interesting I don't know a ton about
doctors a lot of my understanding is
that he's traditionally just kind of a
mad scientist and couldn't actually go
toe-to-toe with the guy Bob we'll see so
Shazam did you see it what did you think
about whatever
it's our drop something down the
comments let's talk about it you know
the stuff to do I don't need to run down
the list I will note the patreon that's
kind of the big thing but the links for
all that stuff very social media blah
blah blah blah it's all down in the
description if you care and in any case
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]